what would you tell an actor over 35
male or female who's maybe coming to LA
for the first time or even a second time
we know like Danny McBride people like
that they had to go back home and pick
themselves up and then come back here
what would you tell that person that's
finding a little bit of a battle in
terms of age well I don't believe in
that I just think that that is a core
belief that Hollywood will make you
believe that you know if you're not
young it's over I don't believe that I
think that are there more parts for
young people than older people there's
parts for older people do you have to be
more established in order to book those
parts you know I don't know that that's
true I think that it has to do with a
certain energy that you are putting
forth in your life and a certain belief
of what you can achieve listen the
moment that you have a thought inside of
you that says I can't get that or I
can't get that part or nobody is gonna
want to see me and then nobody will want
to see you and where you will not get
that part and you have to you have to
believe that you can I don't think it
was the actor that won
the Quentin Tarantino movie the Oscar at
51 that wonderful actor I don't know
that he you know maybe thought well
maybe he did think that he would win
that Oscar but at 51 I mean everything's
possible in the moment that people tell
me that it's not possible I'm determined
to prove them wrong so that's the same
advice that I would give anybody over 35
45 55 and so forth
you